[Music]
i don't know how much it's exaggerated
because the news these days is pretty
much all written for the national
enquirer by all of these i mean it's all
like drama and hyperbole and everything
it i we do miss walter cronkite but um
true because i mean everything's got a
slant to it and so forth but apparently
at some level anyway based on several
articles that have come out uh with elon
musk buying twitter that the uh there's
a lot of people that work at twitter the
the woke type people that are very very
very stressed out
very upset
uh melting down
in various ways that uh they can't work
there if he owns the place that's
absolutely true uh washington post
reported several conversations they had
with twitter employees when it was
announced
on monday of this week that uh that the
deal is going to go through and were
comments like
i'm so stressed out about this i forgot
i have coveted was a direct quote one
was
i literally can't
speak
and yet they were speaking when they
said that
and now it's gotten to the point that
twitter leadership is actually concerned
about this has gone beyond you know
hand-wringing on twitter itself they
took to the platform themselves and you
know uh the sky is falling um you know
all these horrible things about elon
musk who by the way has stated very
clearly that the reason he wanted to buy
is because he he didn't want anybody's
speech
to be altered at all so it's about free
speech but this is apparently a uh an
attack on democracy so here's where we
stand today dave
so twitter leadership has decided that
no changes can be made to the actual
platform at all without the singular
approval of one vice president because
they are concerned as a public statement
by the company they are concerned that
uh some disgruntled uh employees would
try to sabotage the product
okay so now we've got some let's just
stop for a second there though right
there i mean you get past elon musk as a
person i don't know anything about him
um makes battery cars and spaceships
right i mean that's you got it so you
got it i'm not a i'm not a i'm
ambivalent about him i don't know i
don't know enough to say he might be a
great guy he might be a horrible guy i
really don't know
what i'm what the principle i want to
dial in on here is for our listeners
you can take a lesson from this
situation
okay
don't
work
for
someone that you hate
don't work for a company
that you're ashamed of
the leadership or their values
go find another job that's right the
reason is very simple
you will not be good
at what you do
it's impossible to compartmentalize
enough to be excellent at what you do
when you
detest the product
the the owner
the leadership
the you know and because you're not
aligned your values are not aligned and
so all of that to say you're going to
have trouble in a situation like these
twitter employees are in prospering
being successful
if you have this kind of angst
about your new boss that's exactly right
and so uh what you should do is go find
another job yeah it's so simple
and you know you don't have to be
stressed no and be freaked out because
you can be hired in about 20 seconds out
there right now there's a there's a war
on for especially tech people right
that's right and if you know how to work
at twitter somebody will hire you
and but if it i don't care you know i
think that mcdonald's makes horrible
food then don't work at mcdonald's
but you don't get to tell mcdonald's how
to work
you know if you want to tell people how
to do stuff
then you got to go build you a company
that's correct if you are actively
trying to hurt the company you are
pulling a paycheck from i believe it's
tantamount to stealing it is stealing i
really believe that because here's the
deal the minute you are at a point
where you are trying to hurt the company
that is paying you or you are feeling
any kind of other negative emotion you
will not be able to
handle it you can't keep doing it not
only succeeds but it's just called
cognitive dissonance okay yeah it's two
things in your brain that don't both
they can't both be there at the same
time right and be healthy you've got to
be a psychopath that's to
compartmentalize at this level you
cannot do it right and so to s to be
successful in your life embrace the
journey
the thing has changed yeah
and uh you should not work for not for
not for the sake of the people and it's
not a matter of you're protesting by
leaving if you want to say that that's
okay yeah but but the um but but the
deal is
it's not about the company and it's not
about elon it's not about anything it's
about you that's right you
cannot be your best
version of you the most successful
peaceful
fun
version of you when you work at a place
that is not aligned with your values you
think they're crooks that's right or you
think they're going to do harm to
society or you think they're a
narcissist or you think they're whatever
you should not work there that's right
and so we have no problem i have no
problem with these young people or
however old they are being so upset
about uh musk taking over uh but you
need to leave you need to leave soon and
so the professional advice here is it's
going to take six months for him to take
over ownership that's what twitter's
board has said so you have six months
and i'm trying to make this relevant to
people that are listening and watching
right now because if something like this
happens if you don't work on twitter you
work it anywhere else and something
joe's hardware store
and joe sells it to henry and you don't
like him you don't like henry well then
you should you know you don't get to
tell joe and henry how to do the
hardware doyle deal that's their
business they own it that's right
snowflake yeah so you don't get to tell
them how to do their thing if you want
to tell somebody how to do something you
got to be the boss
it means you got to start something that
somebody can [ __ ] about
you got to grow something that somebody
can [ __ ] about so you got to get up off
your butt and go do something but you
can't you don't get to tell other people
how to do that you don't get to tell me
how to drive my car that's my car no but
you do get to leave unless you're a
policeman and then you can but other
than that you can't that's a good point
that's happened before
this is a ramsey show